what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and something really
major has happened in the mcu and if you
haven't seen miss marvel episode 6 we
are going to be talking about some
spoilers not about how it ends but a
very specific scene involving spoiler
alert mutants now even if you haven't
seen miss marvel episode 6 you have
probably heard the news online somewhere
this is one of the biggest announcements
ever in marvel history the mutants are
finally in the mcu so pretty much
everybody is talking about it because it
is super exciting but today we actually
have a little bit of plot details about
how the mutants will actually be in the
mcu and it looks like they're going to
be a threat to society like they have
been in so many story lines we also have
an idea of what their origin could be
like in the mcu which has been a big
mystery ever since the disney fox merger
and some of this news is coming from
marvel.com and miss marvel head writer
and executive producer bishop
ali so it doesn't really get much more
official than that and in this video
we'll try to answer the question have
the mutants been in the mcu the whole
time in which it looks like we pretty
much do have an answer to that and we're
also going to talk about how this may
not be a true origin story of each
member of the x-men and this might not
build up like the avengers did
originally but the x-men could already
exist as a team in the mcu okay so real
quick if somehow you haven't heard that
the mutants are officially in the mcu
well the first one that we've at least
been introduced to is the one and only
kamala khan miss marvel herself no it
does not appear that she is going to be
an inhuman in the mcu but is going to
indeed be a mutant and trust me we'll
talk more about the inhumans in the mcu
in just a bit if you somehow missed it
at the very end of miss marvel episode 6
bruno mentioned that he studied kamala's
brother's dna to kind of check if he had
powers as well in which he didn't but he
discovered that kamala's genes were
different and that they had some type of
mutation yes he literally name-dropped
mutation and then as he said mutation
the theme song from the x-men animated
series played
in your genes
like
like a mutation
[Music]
and to top it all off in the credits we
can actually see it is officially
confirmed it literally credits the x-men
97 theme also marvel.com confirms this
which we'll talk about in just a bit but
first let's talk about a key plot point
of the mutants and the x-men being in
the mcu now which is they probably are
not going to get along with society and
society is probably going to view them
as a threat which is a pretty common
storyline for the x-men this is severely
hinted at after bruno tells kamala that
her genes have some sort of a mutation
where kamala then replies with whatever
it is it's just gonna be another label
this implies that a label is indeed
going to be coming with the mutants and
that typically isn't good there's always
been a big number of the human
population specifically governments that
typically hate mutants in fact we have
several storylines that come from this
fact and it seems like the mcu is going
to be no different just another label
implies that mutants will be labeled and
it doesn't sound like that's going to be
a good label people look up to
superheroes in the mcu but now we have
groups like the dodc who are seemingly
hunting down enhanced individuals and
even shooting at enhanced individuals
that they know are kids so we're already
kind of seeing enhanced individuals
being viewed as threats this is probably
going to be amplified when the mutants
make their way into the mcu which they
already have now but when we start to
see more and see some really powerful
mutants some that can you know walk
through walls or read people's minds or
control magnetic things the governments
of the world and society might start to
feel threatened somewhat of the premise
and storyline of the original x-men
trilogy yes mutants and other enhanced
individuals and superheroes can be good
but what is to stop them from doing bad
this is actually a pretty huge story arc
of the x-men story and is one big factor
that causes a rift between professor
xavier and magneto and it looks like the
mcu will be no different now does this
mean that we're going to be getting a
true origin story of the x-men and each
individual mutant not necessarily think
about the first x-men film it wasn't an
origin story per se it was kind of an
origin story about how wolverine and
rogue joined the x-men it wasn't even a
true origin story about wolverine that
would come later but we don't talk about
bruno and we definitely don't talk about
x-men origins wolverine just ask ryan
reynolds about that now based off of
other events that have happened in miss
marvel and other events in the mcu we
can kind of figure out the origin of the
mutants in the mcu and this might make
some people mad especially fans of the
comics put simply the mutants are
derived from the celestials
experimenting on the human race now
originally this is how we got the
eternals but they completely changed
their origin in the movie instead of the
celestials experimenting on humans and
enhancing them making them celestials
the celestials essentially created
androids this was a really really big
change in the movies from the comics
that's one event that happened the other
is that they pretty much changed kamala
khan's origin story to make it to where
she is not an inhuman but in fact a
mutant and if you're wondering why they
did this and how this works well they
actually explained it in an article on
marvel.com this article was released
shortly after miss marvel episode six
dropped and it is with head writer and
executive producer bishop k ali like i
mentioned before and she exclaims oh my
gosh it was the best day of my life when
she got this news however she revealed
that this wasn't always the plan from
the beginning of the show she said i
feel so excited as a viewer of my show
the bishop teen fan girl in me is like i
can't believe it and she continues to
say and the fact that it's kamala it's
her it's like her wildest dream already
came true over the show gaining powers
but then we just gave her one more bit
of the dream it's incredible i'm
overjoyed and as far as the decision to
make her a mutant goes she says that she
didn't find out until she received the
final draft of the final episode she
says they sent me and only me the draft
of the final episode and i immediately
freaked out i emailed kevin feige in all
caps and was like are you doing this
like for real are you sure i'm so
honored i was like yelling at him
through an email i was freaking out this
is the biggest deal in the world and the
fact that it's happening in our show is
crazy so this wasn't actually the plan
the entire time however it could have
been kevin feige's plan the whole time
but not the writers for miss marvel but
it does actually answer kind of a plot
hole for miss marvel and give us a
little bit about the origin of the
mutants she says it wasn't from the
beginning of the show with marvel
something's always a moving piece and
we're trying to solve this question of
if any of kamala's family put on the
bengal would they have powers the answer
was always no from a character
perspective no and the reason for that
was so it could fit into the logic of
the wider mcu so it seems like kamala
has a active x gene that allows her to
use the powers of the bengal this is why
her brother can't use the bangle her
mother can't use it and presumably her
grandmother can't use it either so it's
not because she's a clandestine that
allows her to use the energy and power
of the bengal it's her x gene but how
did the x gene come about in the mcu
well it most likely came from the cree
experimenting on humans miss marvel
revealed that the cree originally had
the bengal and the origin of the
inhumans was that cree experimented on
humans and other species throughout the
universe this is most likely what is
about to be explored in secret invasion
and the marvels so instead of the
celestials being the ones who
experimented on the humans eventually
causing mutants it might actually be the
kree who are the ones who experimented
on humans causing the x-gene this
however as most people are guessing
would completely eliminate the inhumans
which might be kevin feige's plan the
fact that they put decree in miss marvel
leads us to believe that the cree are
involved somehow probably experimenting
on humans since miss marva was
originally an inhuman but the difference
between an x-men mutant and an inhuman
might be a little hard to see for the
average viewer if you are a casual fan
of marvel movies in the mcu that could
get pretty confusing and that's
something that kevin feige and marvel
studios definitely do not want and if
that's the case and all of this is
adding up which it definitely seems like
it is it looks like the inhumans may not
be a thing in the mcu and if they are
they probably won't be coming for a
pretty long time unless say it's an
alternate universe like we saw in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
later on down the line they might
explain that some mutations are
different than others and some have to
be activated but in the meantime i'm
assuming that it's going to be the cree
who experimented on humans creating the
mutants and that the inhumans aren't
going to be around for a while but let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below and how excited are
you to finally have the mutants in the
mcu keep in mind sdcc is coming up in
less than two weeks now hopefully we'll
get some pretty great answers don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
and of course you can follow me on
twitter and instagram for live updates
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you